hello I am David Kaplan and I am NOT an
expert but I hope in this series to
learn as much as possible and explain it
to you the best way I can what happens
when you fall into a black hole we do
not know if you believe Einstein's
theory of relativity we do know the
person falling into the black hole
crosses the horizon of the black hole
and if the black hole is big enough the
person doesn't notice they just keep on
going and if they get close enough to
the singularity at the center of the
black hole bad things happen to their
body they get stretched out it warped
and the gravity is so strong it's very
bad so we do have a description in that
theory on the other hand in quantum
mechanics if you have a situation where
there is a horizon a surface where
nothing can come out from behind it then
quantum fluctuations at that horizon
produce radiation and the radiation
comes out and you could measure that in
principle but if that energy is coming
out of the black hole even from just the
horizon the black hole should shrink and
eventually disappear and whatever had
fallen into the black hole essentially
disappears and the confusing thing is
that quantum mechanics doesn't predict
the disappearance of any information and
so we would like to understand how the
information that went into the black
hole comes back out and that requires
describing the inside of a black hole
but that means that the theory of
general relativity which predicts
nothing interesting happening at the
horizon smells like it's in
contradiction with the theory of quantum
mechanics which suggests that the
horizon is a very important place so
there's no complete description of the
interior of the black hole which means
we don't know what happens we don't
really care about what happens to
somebody who falls in what we care about
is attempting to describe quantum
mechanics and general relativity in the
same theory and a black hole is the
perfect place because it requires both
you